all right robert
yes sir robert where'd you grow up where
you from i'm from orange county i grew
up in seal beach
i went to los alamitos high school tell
me about your family growing up
well i'm adopted so my birth mom was a
heroin addict and a prostitute my dad
was her pimp
um me and three of my siblings got
adopted by a professional baseball
player and a woman whose construction
company built most of seal beach
um i grew up just an average white boy
at that point in time
i mean just you know she'll beat you
she'll be just a yuppie
yeah i had a pretty good childhood i i
definitely didn't doubt whether or not
they loved me i was afforded all the all
the niceties i got to do all the
baseball and sports and go to church and
vacations and everything else it was uh
the nice 2.5 family only a lot larger
than that
sounds great and how far did you go in
school
i actually have my ged um
my high school equivalency i didn't
quite graduate i was supposed to
graduate and just decided to work
full-time at disneyland instead so
didn't work out that way were you
getting in trouble at that point
um you know at that point in time i'd
touched trouble with the law every once
in a while i think i'd had enjoy riding
maybe i'd ran away from home a couple
times i'd been to uh what caused a youth
shelter or youth shelter in los alamitos
um but nothing big nothing where i'd
actually been to juvenile hall or
you know too much contact with the
police or anything like that it was
mostly just why were you running away
from home
if you had a good childhood well i ran
away from home
not because to be the black sheep i
wanted to be the black sheep i wanted
them to pull the attention off of my
brothers and sisters because we had we
had been adopted
and so i wanted the attention on me and
off of them i didn't want them to get in
trouble for anything so i always did
something
your siblings were from the same family
three of my siblings were from the same
family
same parents yeah well same mom at least
same mom
and then what happened after school well
uh so after school
i did what most kids at 18 did and i
left for the military
um i did four years in the air force uh
and i was honorably discharged
at which point in time i came home and i
started working for an electrical
wholesale company
um i got married i had the kids i did
everything i was supposed to do
everything was pretty all right
i one day in may on may 25th of 2012 my
wife came home and told me that we were
getting a divorce
that she could no longer trust me that i
wasn't emotionally available for her and
at that point in time i started uh i
started using heroin
kind of recreationally i guess at first
i've been an alcoholic since i was nine
years old and going to aaa meetings and
identifying as an alcoholic since i was
nine i still am to this day an alcoholic
i just my alcohol of choice right now
happens to be fentanyl or heroin
so alcohol started early alcohol started
at nine
and i started stealing my parents didn't
drink but they
had parties at the house so there was
always alcohol in the house
uh i started you know replacing the
vodka with water and stealing the beers
that i could during the parties and
whatnot
um and i don't i i guess i drank for
that effect i drank for that oblivion
you know i didn't want to feel i had a
pretty messed up childhood for the first
five years of my life i really didn't
want to paint
the first five years you were with your
my birth family yeah got it uh growing
up in the
we were hotel kids of orange county as
we
as we put it um
and it wait you know i have memories of
those days i do actually i have a lot of
memories of those days some of the most
vivid ones were when i was a little bit
older
and my mom would disappear for weeks at
a time um
doing whatever it was she did but i mean
it was me at the age of like four or
five with three younger siblings
and i would the reason we got caught was
because i got caught stealing from a
taco truck trying to feed
infants m ms and so somebody called
uh the police on as a child support
services on us and they
they came and took us away and that's
how we ended up getting adopted
at one of my court cases or one of the
court cases
uh my mom walked in my birth mom walked
in and said that she didn't want
anything to do with us she wanted to get
high and that the judge could do
whatever they wanted to do with us just
leave her alone at that point in time
and that was kind of the end of that
relationship so
so after your marriage fell apart you
know i
started doing heroin and she took the
kids to south carolina
um i had a couple of years of clarity
somewhere around 2014 2015.
uh and then the woman who i was with at
that point in time left me
and i went straight back to heroin um
and that back in 2015 was my first
experience with skid row
um heroin was a little bit harder to get
in certain places like orange county and
whatnot and somebody had told me about
skid row so i jumped on a bus
not knowing what to expect other than it
was skid row
um and i came down here and i i started
looking for heroin
and uh and it was easy to find and it
was easy to get and i could make money
down here
doing whatever it is i wanted to do uh
predominantly either stealing or
something to do with electronics
um and i would get the money i needed
for heroin i'd get to heroin and i
wouldn't have to go very far to do any
of it so
where do you stay now um i stay off of
uh
like crocker in third right now in a
tent um i still camp out in town
i don't actually have a tent right now
um i sold it so i could get drugs
it tends to be the common denominator in
my life um
but yeah i stay i stay in a little area
that i made right there
um you call it a hut
and your siblings were from the same
family same parents
um well there's three other siblings
from the same parents um it's two two of
my youngest sisters and then my brother
my youngest sister is a problem child
like me we don't have much contact with
her
um and unfortunately my mom just
recently passed and we didn't even see
my sister at the funeral or the memorial
service
um so she's doing what she's doing she's
got two kids she's struggled with
addiction and other problems in her life
um and then my other two siblings my the
older of the two girls and then my
brother who's they're
all younger than me but then my brother
um they're doing really good
she uh my sister is uh the head of
behavioral something or others when it
comes to working with with kids that are
just you know slow learning in schools
in
orange county uh and my brother has a
construction company out in idaho so
they're doing all right they're the
stars of the family right now so what do
you attribute
your current situation to is it genetic
you know what did you inherit it from
your parents
no this is something i chose to do i
mean i know that i could put the work in
i've put the work in to not be here
you know i put the work in to not not
live on skid row i've
i've not lived on skid row my entire
life i didn't grow up around this stuff
i didn't grow up around gangs or drugs
or anything else
you know i didn't see any of that stuff
until you know we knew about it because
of our childhood
but it wasn't actively participating
part of our life growing up
it just it wasn't the way things worked
um
and we were taught the right ways i mean
i really was so now i make a decision
that i want to put a chemical in my body
in order not to feel a certain way and i
don't know what that way is maybe i'll
get there someday maybe i won't who
knows
how old are you i'm 41 years old and you
have kids
i have six kids with in three states
with three women i have five girls and
one boy and my oldest actually just
started school at the citadel so
i'm really proud of my kids my kids are
doing really good in spite of who i am
you talk to them uh not very often not
as often as i'd like but i do get to
speak with them every once in a while
yeah
so going through everything you've gone
through going from a troubled family to
a great family
my own family what have you learned
um
you know i've learned that that no
matter what's going on in my life i can
still be me
if you really want to know the truth
what i've found most important is that i
don't have to give up who i
am in order to continue using this
chemical i can still be the person that
i was raised to be i'm still a good
person i still have a good heart i still
care for people i still reach out for
people i still take care of people
i just happen to have a monkey on my
back you know do you feel like your life
has a purpose
i don't think my life is ever i've never
i don't think i've ever felt that my
life has ever had purpose
i i think i've searched for purpose in
my life um
and because of who i am and how i see
myself and what i believe i'm capable of
i don't think i've ever gotten there and
what about getting clean one day
do you see that in your future i hope so
i hope so have you ever been clean
i have i had nine years sober at one
point nine years yeah
yeah and it was silver from everything
from june alcohol or heroin
everything i when i say sober i mean
sober i didn't i didn't take a pill that
wasn't
prescribed for me i didn't i didn't
drink i didn't use anything no no
chemicals
no suboxone no anything um and i did
that i did that for nine years up until
2012-ish
and what got you to relapse uh my wife
leaving
women women tend to be my problem women
and kids are my problem
i care too much and uh and then i don't
show up i don't produce
what do you think could have been
different about your
life your childhood that may have
changed that
you know that's a good question i ask
myself that all the time you know i tell
people i have a god problem because i
have a problem with some things god's
doing in my life
um but then i come to certain realities
like there is a god and i'm not him that
it's probably gonna work out better
doing it his way
anyways and i can't stop talking about
him no matter what i do
so i don't think there's any one moment
in time that i can really pinpoint
that would change anything because i'm
not quite sure that there's anything
after any point in time in my life where
i would want to sacrifice having that
you know if i go back to being with my
wife and my kids then there's two other
kids that i don't have and if at any
point in time i decide not to do
something
then there's something that doesn't
happen that's a positive and and whether
it be a positive for me or my kids or
my family whatever it might be it's not
something i'm willing to sacrifice so i
can't pinpoint
when might have happened and this
lifestyle that has
no responsibility at all
what do you make of that um do you enjoy
it
you know i i don't like not having any
responsibility i continue to
search for ways to responsibility tends
to give life meaning
right the responsibilities you know it's
simple as
i i can unlock a phone which is a talent
not a lot of people have
you know um and so i i market that you
know and i'm on i
i'm on offer up and i'm on craigslist
and i'm trying to normalize
something and then and then i don't want
to be normal you know i don't want to go
to work every day i don't want to
wake up in the same bed with the same
person with the same kids
i don't necessarily want that but at the
same time i'd rather have that than what
i currently have
what do you think most people who don't
do drugs don't understand about
addiction
that to some extent it's not necessarily
a choice like my body has to have i have
to have heroin or fentanyl in my body i
have to have some sort of opioid in my
system or it makes me sick
i hear this a lot it may have been a
choice that very first time that you
tried it
right it was the euphoria at first but
then after that
it become a necessity yes it becomes
life or death
and at some point in time it does become
life or death
what's your biggest regret my kids
my kids my kids deserve to have a father
i miss my kids
what emotions do you deal with now uh
anger
i'm angry at myself i'm in greek god um
sadness you know
i miss my kids i don't know yeah i
didn't expect to be a father i didn't
expect to have kids i really didn't
because of the type of person i was
and now to have such amazing kids and
not participate in their life on a
regular basis is killing me
that's a weight that's hard to bear
isn't it oh yeah
it's not fun but i still make my choices
that i make
you know i just hope at some point in
time i decide to do something different
and it's not too late
all right robert i wish you the best of
luck thank you very much thank you i
appreciate that
no problem of course
you